hello
i'm ryan wright
and i'm jerry
welcome to reasons to see where we give
you reasons to see and maybe not to see
anchorman 2 the legend continues
you stay classy
planet earth
reasons to see
the cast is still funny
yeah so we just saw anchorman 2 not
together jerry didn't want to come with
me to watch anchorman too i had to work
it's [ __ ] up man we don't watch movies
together anymore i'm sorry it hurts my
feelings a little bit i didn't realize
this was a wednesday release so i was
like oh
let's cram it somewhere into thursday
right so yeah anchorman 2 um the legend
continues i thought this song was
[ __ ] hilarious i had a great time
i
thought it was pretty funny i enjoyed
the movie most certainly like and
especially you know more so since i left
the theater if you're talking criticism
it is not a
an entirely
complete film in my opinion but i still
had fun i still completely disagree i
thought it was a complete film in a lot
of ways i thought it'd have more
character arcs to it there was more
sincere emotional moments not not a lot
but there was like
two or three scenes of that i even like
the little b story with brick and uh the
woman
played by
that famous woman kristen wayne
christian
i mean i like all those things on
principle i'm like
like i like the subplot with kristen
wiig because i like steve caron kristen
wiig more than i thought it was actually
inspired don't listen to this guy hi it
was hilarious i laughed
a good amount of time i had a hoot i was
laughing uncontrollable uncontrollably i
was filled with joy the mountain of zeus
was throwing lightning to my heart ron
burgundy still has it man i thought ron
burgundy needs the [ __ ] i like kind of
this different version on him he seems
like a much more relaxed version of ron
burgundy really i'm just saying like the
way will ferrell did it like will
ferrell have seemed to have more energy
than the first one it's not a bad
performance at all it's not it's not a
non-energetic performance you know he it
was cool to see him like learn to be a
dad and the way anchorman would have him
learn to be a dad
you know or how to appreciate his wife
you know knowing what really comes first
and everything like the obvious lessons
you see coming early on in the film i
thought he was really funny too in a in
a comfortable kind of way i guess for me
but i also like it more
having left in theater so who knows all
i cared about was will romberg and he
still be funny and he had me cracking up
quite a few amount of times not a few
why'd i say that i was laughing
hysterically sometimes man my issues
with this movie sort of carry through
everything it's sort of like everything
is consistent in a way in the sense that
everything is a little bit half
formulated to me it's like every
character is a little bit more blunt
force in this movie ron burgundy's funny
because ron burgundy's funny if for no
other reason than ron burgundy's funny
no i thought um i liked how they took
every character more to the extreme in
this one ryan's consensus a hilarious
ball of a time is the reason to see
anchorman 2 the legend continues a
hilarious ball of a time is the reason
to see anchorman 2 the legend continues
yeah i just had a really good time
i [ __ ] loved it
jerry's consensus good time with some
old pals is the reason to see anchorman
2 the legend continues a good time with
some old pals is the reason to see
anchorman 2 the legend continues yeah
this movie to me is like it's like
getting together with a bunch of old
friends it makes you reminiscent of the
glory days but you're still like that's
a good bunch of guys though i like
seeing them alright guys thanks for
checking out our review for anchorman 2
the legend continues why don't you go
ahead and scroll that comment box below
and tell us what's your favorite news
channel yeah then once you're done with
that
you're going to want to check out more
episodes of reason to see right so if so
click this button here and last but not
least if you want to get updated
every time
one of our reviews or our videos is out
subscribe
you're going to want to do it you are
it's the right choice you do right now
or a spawn will
swallow you
a spawn yeah like the comic book
character
to be honest i'm not entirely sure what
a spawn is
you